[موسيقى]
في العشرين من مارس عام 2003 تسمر العالم
امام شاشات التلفاز في متابعه بدايه الغزو
الامريكي للعراق اطلق على العمليات
العسكريه اسم الحريه من اجل العراق وجرت
تمهيد لها بمبررات عديده ثبت زيفها مع
الوقت على مدار 20 عاما لم تمحى اثار
وتداعيات استراتيجيه الصدمه والترويع التي
تبناها الامريكيون في عملياتهم باحتلال
هذا البلد خسائر بشريه بمئات الالاف
وماديه تقدر بتريليونات الدولارات
وتغييرات جذريه في العراق والمنطقه وحتى
في الولايات المتحده في قصتنا الليله
عشرون عاما على الغزو الامريكي للعراق
واجهنا من كان في واجهه هذا الغزو في
الاسئله التي لا تزال تطرح الى اليوم عن
جدوى هذا الغزو وما حمله للعراقيين بعد ان
بشرهم بالحريه والديمقراطيه في مقابله
خصنا بها الجنرال ديفيد بترويس القائد
السابق للقوات الامريكيه في العراق اجاب
بصراحه على اسئلتنا عن هذه الحرب غير انه
اعترف لنا ان هناك سؤالا واحدا لن يجيب
عليه على الاطلاق وهو هل كان غزو العراق
قرارا صائبا ام لا ولعل في بعض الصمت
اجابه ابلغ وجهنا ايضا الحاكم المدنيه
الامريكي للعراق في فتره الغزو بالازمات
التي تسببت فيها قراراته كحل الجيش
العراقي واشتثاث البعث اقر الرجل بان اكبر
خطا ارتكبه هو تفويض السلطه تنفيذ قرار
اشتتتات حزب البعث الى الحكومه العراقيه
المؤقته انذاك لتنطلق عمليه تصفيه حسابات
سياسيه ضد الخصوم ناقشنا مع ساسه عراقيين
من مختلف المشارب رؤيتهم للغزو الامريكي
ومبرراته وما ال اليه حال بلدهم باسى يوضح
احدهم ان العراقيين وان تمتعوا بحريه
حرمهم منها نظام صدام حسين انهم غير
راضيين عن حال البلد اقتصادا وخدمات عامه
ومؤسسات قصدنا ذلك من خلال تتبع مسار ترد
الخدمات العامه في البلاد خلال سنوات
الحصار وحتى ما بعد الغزو اما بقيه قصتنا
نستكملها مع ضيفينا الدكتور جاسم الموسوي
الباحثه السياسي والمتخصص في القانون
الدولي والدكتور يحيى الكبيسي الباحث
والكاتب السياسي نبحث مع ضيفين الكريمين
التغيرات التي جرت في بنيه الدوله
والمجتمع العراقيين بعد عقدين من الغزو
الامريكي وامكانيه اصلاح بنيه النظام
السياسي وتعديل او تغيير الدستور العراقي
في ضوء المطالبات المستمره بذلك وفرص عوده
العراق الى دوره الاقليمي بعيدا عن اي
تاثيرات خارجيه وكذا مستقبل الوجود
الامريكي في العراق لكن لنشاهد القصه بدءا
وبعدها النقاش
مع بزوغ فجر العشرين من مارس 2003 شنت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مع الحلف الذي
تقوده اولى هجماتها على العراق وعلى الرغم
من النتائج الاوليه التي اعطت انطباعا بان
هذا الغزو كان سريعا وحاسما الا انه تسبب
بتداعيات وتغييرات جذريه مستمره في العراق
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه ودول المنطقه
على مدار 20 عاما
اعتقد انه من المهم ان نكون واضحين بخصوص
الوضع عندما وصلنا الى العراق قبل ان نغزو
ونحرر العراقيين العراق كان بلدا غنيا جدا
وعندما تولى صدام الحكم كان اجمالي الناتج
المحلي للعراق اعلى من اسبانيا وعندما
اتيت الى العراق كان اجمالي ناتج المحلي
العراقي بمستوى انغولا الكثير من الضرر
لاحق بالاقتصاد خلال حكم صدام من الظلم ان
تقيم الحاله قبل احتلال العراق بمرحله
زمنيه قريبه جدا من الاحتلال وهي مرحله
الحصار
في التسعينات
وانما ينبغي لنا النظر الى موضوع العراق
في التاريخ الحديث والمعاصر له ما حصل في
العراق بعد الاحتلال من فشل على كل الصعود
لا يمكن ابدا ربطه بالمرحله التي وصل
اليها العراق في الزمان الحصار وحتى ان تم
الربط فالمتسبب واحد وهو الاحتلال
الامريكي
ما قبل سنوات الحصار الذي فرضته الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه عام 1990 عاش العراق
بحسب العديد من الاحصاءات الرسميه
العالميه سنوات من الازدهار في شتى مجالات
الحياه
وبحسب تقرير اليونيسف الصادر عام 2014 عن
التعليم في العراق فان العراق ما قبل عام
1991 كان يمتلك احد افضل الانظمه
التعليميه في المنطقه وكانت نسبه الاميه
للفئه العمريه من 15 الى 45 عاما اقل من
عشره في المئه حتى عام
وكان معدل الانفاق الحكومي على التعليم
يبلغ 20% من معدل اجمالي الميزانيه
الحكوميه لتستمر مؤشرات جوده التعليم في
العراق بالتراجع منذ عام
1991 حتى عام 2003
وعلى المستوى الاقتصادي يشير التقرير الذي
اعدته خدمه ابحاث الكونجرس عام 2003 الى
ان العراق في الثمانينيات كان يمتلك احد
افضل الاقتصادات في العالم العربي
عندما حصل الاحتلال حصل بعد مرحلتين مرحله
حرب الثمانينات وحصار التسعينات ولان
العراق يعتمد بالاساس على النفط كاقتصاد
ريعي ومنع تصدير النفط خلال 13 سنه
فبالتاكيد يتاثر
الاقتصاد منع التصدير بحجه اسلحه دمار
الشامل وهذه ذريعه امريكيه هم اكدوا انها
كذب وعندما تمنع موارد الاقتصاد الاساسيه
بالتاكيد يكون هناك تضخم وتكون هناك اخطار
فيما يتعلق بالنجاعه والتعليم في كلام
البريمه لشيء من الصحه وفي كلام المقابل
ايضا اشياء من الصحه فالنظام الديكتاتوري
السابق كان بصراحه كارثه على الشعب
العراقي لانه خاض حروبا تلوى اخرى حرب ضد
الشعب الكردي حرب ضديران ثمان سنوات
واحتلال الكويت في الجانب الاخر صحيح انه
التعليم في العراق كان
جيدا ومحو الاميه كانت يعني برنامج شامله
من الستينات
واصبح في نهايه الثمانينات درجه الاميين
في العراق نسبه يعني متدنيه جدا قياسنا
الى دول المنطقه
[موسيقى]
استمرت سنوات الحصار الذي فرضته الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه على العراق قرابه 13
عاما مع كل ما حملته تلك السنين من بؤس
وعناء للشعب العراقي
[موسيقى]
بدا الحرب العسكريه في العشرين من مارس
اعتقد ان السبب الرئيسي لغزو العراق تمثل
حول فكره وجود ديكتاتور قاتل شنه هجمات
على دولتين جارتين في الماضي
بالاضافه الى تقدير الاستخبارات الامريكيه
بانه كان هناك نوع ما من اسلحه الدمار
الشامل في العراق
وكان هذا فشلا استخباراتيا كبيرا
كان موجود
استطاع صدام حسين حقيقه ان يخفي كثير من
الاسلحه الكيماويه وعمليه من المواد
الكيمياويه ليس الصحيحه بالتاكيد حقيقيه
وفي مكانيا كانت موجوده في شمال العراق في
بنجاويين انضربت
شاهدنا الحقيقه جثث والاف الاكراد اللي
مستشهدين
وعشتها في البصره
بعد ما ضربت المدافع المواد الكيمياويه
واكستها
الرياح على القوات العراقيه في وقتها
سرعان ما اتت رياح التغيير الامريكيه
بنتائج معاكسه اذ تشير دراسه اعدها المركز
الدولي للعداله الانتقاليه عام 2013 ان
رئيس الاداره المدنيه للاشراف على اعاده
اعمار العراق بول بريمر اتخذ فور تعيينه
في مايو 2003 عده قرارات تسببت بازمات
وتصدعات متراكمه مثل قرارات اجتثاث البعث
وحل الجيش العراقي والاستعجال في تاسيس
نظام الانتخابي قائم على المحاصصه
الطائفيه
الخطا الذي ارتكبناه هو قولنا او
استخدامنا لمصطلح حل الجيش العراقي لانه
لم يكن هناك جيش الجيش هرب لقد حل نفسه
بنفسه ببساطه عندما راى الجيش مجرى الحرب
لدى بالفرار لقد كنا صريحين للغايه ففي
حاله الجيش اي شخص برتبه عقيدنا وقل اراد
الانضمام الى الجيش الجديد رحبنا به وكما
اشرت
ايضا وجود الميليشيات الشيعيه
عمليه حل الجيش
اتاح لذوي النفوس الضعيفه ان يذهبون
ويسرقون ويحتلون
مؤسسات ومنشات
وماكو لا شرطه ولا جيش ولا كذا وبالتالي
صار البلد في التيه يعيش بصراحه يعني كان
قرار غير سليم جدا
بحل الجيش العراقي والمؤسسات الاخرى
كان عام 2005 عمل انزلاق الى الفوضى
تشير الاحصاءات التي تبنتها دراسه وضعها
المركز الديمقراطي العربي الى ان اعمال
العنف في العراق كانت تحصد نحو 30 قتيلا
كل يوم خلال عامي
ثم اخذت في الارتفاع مع نهايه عام 2005
لتصل الى خمسين قتيلا وازدادت الى اكثر من
100 جثه في اليوم مع منتصف عام 2006
لقد ادركنا ان الطريقه الوحيده لتامين
الشعب وهي المهمه الاساسيه بالنسبه لنا هي
التفكير انه من واجبنا تامين وخدمه الشعب
العراقي من خلال العوده الى الاحياء
واثبات وجودنا هناك بالتعاون مع القوات
العراقيه وبذلك تمكنا بمرور الوقت من
تقليص هذا العنف الرهيب الذي سبق زياده
قواتنا في العراق
خطه بترايوس وخطه الامريكيه نجحت في تقليل
هجمات المقاومه
ويشهد العالم تداعيات خطيره من ذلك
الوقت الحين او على الاقل بعد عام 2009
هذه التداعيات
انتشرت بشكل اخر وما يمكن تسميته بالسلفيه
الجهاديه في العراق منذ ذلك الوقت اصبح
العراق او عراقيون الان ينتشرون ليس في
العراق والشام فقط وانما وصلوا الى سيناء
والى افريقيا والى الفلبين وافغانستان وفي
باكستان وربما في مره اخرى
[موسيقى]
نتيجه لانعدام الامن في البلاد تاثرت كافه
اشكال الحياه في العراق فعلى مستوى
التعليم مثلا تشير الدراسه التي نشرها
مركز جنيف العالمي للعداله في عام 2013
الى ان 84% من المؤسسات التعليميه في
العراق قد دمرت اوطالها الدمار كما تم
اغتيال
467 محاضرا واستادا منذ عام 2003 العراق
ان الدول او ما يسمى بلدان العالم الثالث
التي تمكنت من تحقيق قفزه كبيره في
التعليم خلال الثمانينات اما الان الاطفال
لا يجدون في كثير من المناطق ما يوفر لهم
قوتهم اليومي لهذا
تسربون من المدارس
لم تقف تداعيات الغزو الامريكي للعراق
داخل البلاد بل تجاوزتها لتحدث تغييرات
جوهريه في المنطقه حيث بدات المخاوف تتسلل
الى الدول المجاوره من تصاعد النفود
الايراني في العراق
الحكومه العراقيه بفضل ما قمنا به هي
حكومه ذات سياده لها دستور وعليهم ان
يجدوا الحل بانفسهم من الواضح انهم
يواجهون سلسله من المشاكل واخطرها زياده
النشاط والسيطره والنفوذ الايراني لانه
باعتقادي الحكومه في طهران لا تفكر
انطلاقا من كونها ايرانيه بل من كونها
فارسيه والفرس دائما يطمحون لحكم
امبراطوريات كبرى
[موسيقى]
التركيبه كامله في المنطقه تغيرت الوضع
السياسي تغير الوضع الامني تغير
والاقتصادي بل حتى الوضع الثقافي كان
كثيرون في البدايه همهم بعض الاطراف في
المنطقه هو تغيير النظام بسبب مشاكل سابقه
هذه التخوفات جعلت كثيرين في المنطقه
ينظرون الى اسقاط نظام صدام حسين كانه
اسقاط لشخص لمجموعه حول نظام صدام حسين
لحزب حزب البعث ولكنهم لم يدركوا انه
اسقاط لمنظومه سياسيه لمدوله قائمه
لمؤسسات دوله سيكون لانهيار يتداعيات
كبيره لا على العراق فحسب للمنطقه وحذرنا
من ذلك
استمر الوجود الامريكي العسكري في العراق
قرابه 8 سنوات وفي ديسمبر 2011 اعلن
الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق باراك اوباما
قرارا انسحاب القوات الامريكيه المقاتله
من العراق بعد ان تكبدت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه خسارات كبيره على المستوى
المادي والمعنوي حيث قدرت الاحصاءات
الرسميه لوزاره الدفاع الامريكيه اعداد
القتلى الامريكيين في العراق منذ عام 2003
وحتى عام 2011 بقرابه
4500 قتيل وتسببت بقتل نحو 200 الف عراقي
طبقا لهيئه احصاءات ضحايا حرب العراق كما
وصلت الخسائر الماديه في عمليه الغزو الى
تريليون ومئه مليار دولار حسب دراسه
اعدتها جامعه براون والتي تعتقد ان الرقم
سيصل الى تريليونين ومئتين مليار دولار
بعد عام 2050
لرعايه المحاربين القدامى والمصابين
وتبعات اخرى
الخسائر في العراق وفي افغانستان تقدر
بالتريليونات الموضوع يعتمد على كيفيه
الحساب والتنبؤ لبعض الاثار التي ترتبت
على الذين اصيبوا بجروح خطيره وتكاليف
الرعايه الصحيه وغير ذلك وهذه الخسائر
ليست بسيطه بل هي باهظه للغايه لذلك نعم
كانت تلك التكلفه عاليه جدا وتساؤل الناس
في ضوء ذلك حول ما اذا كنا قد فعلنا
الصواب ام لا هو تساؤل مشروع لكن كما قلت
ان الاجابه الوحيده التي لن اقدمها على
الاطلاق هي هل كان غزونا للعراق تصرفا
صحيحا ام لا لانني كتبت الكثير من رسائل
التعزيه للامهات والاباء والاخوه والاخوات
الامريكيين
تركت حرب العراق تبعات سياسيه على مستوى
عالمي وفي مراجعه جديده قدمتها منشورات
جامعه اوكسفورد في مطلع عام 2023 بعنوان
بعد مرور 20 عاما على حرب العراق نحو بنيه
اقليميه جديده رات الدراسه ان حرب العراق
قد ساعدت على تاكل اسطوره القوات المطلقه
الغربيه وفتح الشرق الاوسط كمساحه تنافسيه
للفرص الاقتصاديه والاستراتيجيه وكان ذلك
جزءا من تحول مستمر واسع من القطبيه
الاحاديه الى تعدديه قطبيه اكبر في
المنطقه والعالم اجمع
اعتقد انه من الصعب جدا الاجابه على هذا
السؤال لانه واسع وفضفاض جدا هناك الكثير
من الاشياء التي حدثت في امريكا خلال
السنوات العشرين السابقه هناك تطور كامل
من خلال الاتفاق الابراهيمي الذي يسعى الى
تحريك الاتجاه الاخر في المنطقه انا لا
اعمل في الحكومه الامريكيه الان لكنني
اعتقد انها فعلت شيئا جيدا من خلال اعداد
اتفاقيات ابرهام ما زالت انك تدفع فاتوره
الخسائر المعنويه والماديه
والاخلاقيه في العراق امريكا الان تعاني
من موقف اخلاقي كبير وهي انها لم تنجح في
بناء عقديمقراطي كما قالت لم تنجح في بناء
نظام سياسي سليم لم تنجح في بناء عمليه
سياسيه يشترك فيها جميع العراقيين ونتائج
الانتخابات الاخيره دليل واضح على ذلك
فباختصار استطيع ان اقول امريكا خسرت
الحرب في العراق من هذا المنظار بعد
من الغزو الامريكي للعراق ما يزال
العراقيون يعيشون تبعات ذلك الغزو ولم
تقدم حرب الحريه من اجل العراق حتى اليوم
ما وعدت به العراقيين من بلد مستقر
ومستقبل زاهر
رحبوا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام وبضيفي
الكريمين من بغداد الدكتور جاسم الموسوي
الباحث السياسي والمتخصص في القانون
الدولي ومن اسطنبول الدكتور يحيى الكبيسي
وهو الكاتب والباحث السياسي العراقي اهلا
بضيفينا الكريمين لعلنا نبدا معك دكتور
جاسم الموسوي سمعت تلك الاعترافات التي
وان لم تكن صريحه مئه بالمئه عن مدى صواب
قرار غزو العراق وفق منظور امريكي
وبحسابات امريكيه بعد الخسائر التي
تكبدتها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي
تشكك طبعا في هذا القرار لكن والعراقي
اليوم ينظر الى الامام ويتطلع لبناء بلده
النظر الى الخلف الى عشرين سنه مضت كيف
يرى الموضوع برمته
يعني في البدايه تحيه للجنابك والى الضيفي
الكريم والى مشاهدي قناه الجزيره اولا
دعيني انا اتحفظ على
ضيفين لهما موقف متطرف كبير جدا وهم
الدكتور مثنى والدكتور وليد الذي يعمل في
مركز يديره الشيخ خبيث الخنجر وهو الشريك
في العمليه السياسيه وهذا التناقض هو الذي
شوه السمعه يعني وجه النظام السياسي
والسوداؤيه التي خرجت في التقرير لا
تحقيقه لا تبث لك
ملكه تماما لكن هما ايضا ضيفان في هذا
البرنامج ونحن حارسنا ان نستمع لمختلف
الاصوات من العراق طبعا انا اعطيهم الحق
اعطيهم الحق عراقيين بالعكس هذا واحد من
منجزات
الحراك السياسي ان تكون هناك ايدولوجيات
مختلفه وعلى الملا بالعكس تعالي بالعراق
لدينا عشرات القنوات بالمنجزات ما بعد
سقوط النظام لدينا مئات الصحف لدينا
اذاعات لدينا الراي والراي الاخر لدينا
تعدديه لدينا نظام برلماني كنا نعيش منذ
الى03 تحت حكم العسكر نظام احادي يحكم
بالقوه لا يمكن ان يسقط الا بمطرقه من
الخارج صحيح دفعنا تكاليف الغزو الامريكي
ولكن ايضا تعالي الى الجهه الاخرى التي
تشاهدون بها فصل بين السلطات هذا الحراك
الجماهيري الوعي بدات هناك ثقافه سياسيه
تشاهدينا من اقصى اليمين الى اقصى اليسار
من يتحرك بحريه كامله من يقرا من يخاطب
ايضا لاول مره حتى في موضوع خروج
التظاهرات التي تقبل في بعض الاحيان وكان
هناك نعم اخطاء لكن تعرفين اني اول مره
المواطن يعرف حقوقه وواجباته من النظام
السياسي تتحدثين عن نظام سياسي ثابت وغير
متحرك كالانظمه السابقه التي انا منذ
ولاده مواليد 1964 شهاده رئيسين احمد حسن
بكر وصدام واصبحت جدوى خاصه الدعم يدير
العراق وهذا بكل تاكيد انجاز كبير ان
يتغير الرؤساء يتغير الوزراء ولدينا
منجزات اخرى على المستوى الاجتماعي لدي
مواطن عراقي وتقاعدون رواتب
فيروز الله يخليك
ست فيروز ست فيروز اولا لدينا تسعه مليون
ونص بين متقاعد بين فدائي صدام الاجهزه
الامنيه الحرس القديم الجيش العراقي
المتقاعدين السجناء السياسيين يتقاضون
راتبلون حوالي اربعين مليون عراقي او اكثر
من اربعين مليون عراقي المستوى المعاشي
التي تتحدثين تتحدثون عنه هو افضل من نظام
من النظام السابق عشرات المرات
البعث الذي تحدثتم عنه وليس فكرا هو
منظومه السلطه اختزل العراق بالبعث وصلاح
الدين صلاح الدين بالعوجه العوجه بالعائله
والعائله بالرئيس السابق الذي بكل تاكيد
ورحل الى الى ربه بكل تاكيد تتحدثين انت
على انتقاله هناك منعطف كبير اصبح في
تاريخ السياسي العراقي وتلاحظين ان هناك
مساحات للتغيير وامل للتطوير الان العراق
يشبه 2007 العراق بكل تاكيد لا يشبه 2007
بمعنى ان النظام الديمقراطي واحده من
عوامل نجاح النظام هو ان يتانى في التطوير
ان لا يستعجل في التطوير وليس نظاما عاديا
وبالتالي لا اقول ليس هناك فساد بالي
واداري لا اقول لا توجد ميليشيات ولكن
ايضا اقول بكل صراحه هذا النظام السياسي
افضل من اي نظام سياسي اخر ودعيني اقول
بكل صراحه ان البيئه السنيه سوق لها
بالخطا الكبير ان تحتضن او تتفرج او تشاهد
او تدعم الارهاب الذي عكر بناء الدوله
العراقيه ما بعد سقوط النظام وحتى موضوع
الجيش كما اشاروا لم يكن هناك جيشا عراقيا
لذلك هناك انتقاله كبيره الان تاثير ان
ادعوك شخصيا ان تزور العراق وتشاهدين في
المتنبي حتى الكتب المتطرفه موجوده وهذا
لم يحصل في تاريخ العراق الان كل من يريد
ان يتحدث وينتقد النظام وينتقد شخوص
النظام ليس له الحق ايضا وضع السكه لاول
مره للدوله العراقيه وهو سكه عندما تكون
هناك خلافات سياسيه لدينا محكمه اتحاديه
حتى هذه الاعتراض لكن ايضا في نقطه كبيره
نعم نعم دكتور جاسم ساعود يعني حتى نقسم
الوقت ونسمع وجهه نظر الدكتور يحيى ساعود
اليك يعني لا شك دكتور يحيى مثل ما ذكر
ضيفنا الكريم دكتور جاسم بانه هناك خطوات
كبيره وانجازات كبيره حققت في العراق هناك
الان عمليه سياسيه هناك انتخابات هناك نوع
من الامن
والاستقرار ان صح التعبير كما وصفه الرئيس
العراقي حال العراق اليوم لا يشبه باي حال
من الاحوال مكان منذ سنوات قليله مضت ما
الذي يستند عليه ايضا المشككون في الوضع
العراقي الان بانه حتما بات افضل
يعني بدايه مساء الخير وللمشاهدي قناه
الجزيره ولضيفك الكريم من بغداد يعني
بالتاكيد نحن نتحدث هنا عن بنيتي نظامين
مختلفين يعني بنيه نظام ديكتاتوري وبنيه
نظام اريد له ان يكون نظام ديمقراطي ولكنه
فشل في هذه الديمقراطيه ونتج عن ذلك
احتكار احادي للسلطه على اساس طائفي يعني
بعيدا عن الشكل الذي يعني يراد تسويقه
للعراق بالنهايه العراق ليس بلدا
ديمقراطيا هناك شكل ديمقراطي خالي من اي
محتوى حقيقي كل القوانين الشموليه التي
انتجها نظام ما قبل 2003 والانظمه
الديكتاتوريه التي سبقت حتى العام 68 ما
زالت عامله هناك يعني نوع من
حقيقه مطارده لاي كلمه
تختلف عن ما يراد له في العراق هناك نوع
من خنق الح هناك نوع من اسكات الاطراف
المعارضه لا وجود لمعارض في العراق
المعارض في العراق اما يكون في السجن واما
يكون منفي يعني بعيدا
العراق منذ عام 2019 قد
تعود مره اخرى
حتى الاحتجاجات وجهت بالعنف وجهت بالدم
يعني احتجاجات العمل في 2019 نتجه عنها
اكثر من 800 شهيد واكثر من عشرين الف جريح
ولم يحاسب احد من الذين اتخذوا هذا القرار
يعني قرار القتل او قرار استخدام الاسلحه
تجاه متظاهرين عزل لم يحاسبهم النظام
بالتاكيد نحن نتحدث عن بنيه نظام مختلفه
نتحدث عن دستور مختلف ولكنه دستور طائفي
ونظام سياسي طائفي ان نتحدث عن ان الفساد
اصبحت جزءا من بنيه النظام السياسي وانه
الفساد اصبح جزءا من بنيه الدوله نتحدث
هنا عن التزوير المنهجي للانتخابات نتحدث
عن احتكار السلطه عن الزبائنيه التي تحكم
النظام السياسي العراقي وبالتالي محاوله
تسويق اشكال بعيدا عن المحتوى الحقيقه هذا
فيه نوع من التظليل بمعنى عندما نتحدث عن
انتخابات ونقول ان هذه الانتخابات غير
نزيهه انتخابات فيها تزوير كبير هذا
بالتاكيد يلغي فكره الانتخابات من الاصل
بمعنى الحديث عن تكافؤ فرص الحديث عن
امكانيه الوصول هناك احتكاك
حتى وان شابتها بعض النقائص كما تقول
ساعود اليك دعني اتحول للدكتور جاسم
الموسوي ضيفنا الكريم من اسطنبول دكتور
يحيى اشار الى نقطه مهمه وهي الفساد
السياسي الذي اعترف به حتى اساس عراقيون
رئيس الوزراء في مقابله للجزيره ستبث
لاحقا تحدث عن هذا الفساد اقر بوجوده وقال
بانه سيحاربه عبر الطرق القانونيه ما الذي
يفسر استمرار الفساد واستمرار ربما هذه
المعدلات الكبيره
الفقر في بلد يفترض انه من اغنى الدول في
العالم
ست فيروز يعني اولا اخي دكتور يحيى شارك
بالانتخابات وبالتالي كان مؤمن بالنظام
السياسي والمشروعيه النظام ولو كان النظام
كما تفضل احادي هذه اغلبيه هذا هو الشعب
العراقي الاغلبيه الشيعيه وبالتالي نتائج
الانتخابات بكل تاكيد
وليس عيبا اما وجود اتفق مع الدكتور يحيى
وجود نمطيه طائفيه تقاد من خلالها
الانتخابات ايضا هو هذا واقع اثبات الوجود
وبالتالي ليس
اقليه في بلد يريد ان يكون ديموقراطيا
الديمقراطيه لا تلغي الاقليه بل على العكس
تضمن حقوق هذه الاقليه وتضمن ان تصل ايضا
لدوائر الحكم اليس كذلك
ست فيروز فصل كامل للحقوق والحريات اولا
النظام البرلماني هو نظام تتشكل من خلال
الاحزاب صحيح قد لم تصل الى الان ثقافه ان
تتفق القوى السياسيه على اساس برنامج وطني
وبالتالي تذوب يعني يذوب هذا الشكل الذي
يشاهدون من خلاله وراي الجمهوريه الكردي
ورئيس برلمان اما الاقليات التي تتحدثين
عنها هي اقليات ايضا يعني منصهره مع الكتل
السياسيه ولديها ادوار في السلطه
التنفيذيه والديها وزارات ولاحظ التشكيل
وخارطه الوزارات في العراق هي خارطه يشارك
بها جميع العراقيين بكل مسمياتهم دعيني
اقول شيء مهم جدا النظام السياسي نظام
صحيح ويتناسب مع العراق ولكن السلوك في
النظام السياسي والخطا بمعنى ان السلوك
الذي ادى الى الفساد المالي والاداري هو
استثمار من قوه سياسيه فشلت حقيقه في ان
تشكل الهويه الوطنيه بطريقه عموديه في
بناء العراق وبالتالي استفادت واستثم
واستغلت المال العراقي وسرقت المال
العراقي وهذا بكل تاكيد بدا ينقرض الان
بدانا ان نشاهد حاله جديده هناك ربما
تنازل من القوه السياسيه للسيد السوداني
بعد التظاهرات الكريمه والكبيره التشريريه
التي شهدت والتي ضغطت على هذه القوه
السياسيه وبدا الان الفساد لا اقول ينتهي
ولكن بدا يحاصر بشكل كبير
الفقر الشعب العراقي هذا الكلام غير دقيق
اولا
عفوا
ولكن
هناك من يقول بان بنيه المؤسسات مؤسسات
الدوله القائمه على هذه المحاصصه الحزبيه
والطائفيه هي المعرقل في الواقع امام
تحسين عمل هذه المؤسسات
صحيح
صحيح كلام دقيق جدا وكلام منطقي
والوزارات قسمت لكن دعيني اقول ربما
المرحله الاولى من حكومه السيد السوداني
وزعت وهذا انا بتقديري ربما ستكون خطوه
ولبنه دعيني اقول لك وبكل صراحه 2025
ستجرد جميع الحرس القديم وهذا سجليه لم
يعد لم تعد هناك اسماء كنا نشاهدها كانت
تتقاسم بالسلطه الان نتحدث عن خوف من بعض
القوى السياسيه
وبمناسبه فيروس حتى هذا التمسك بالوزارات
وتسويه الوزارات واستغلال الوزارات هو
للدفاع او دعيني اقول لتقديم دفعات لكي لا
يحال هؤلاء للمحاكمات اقول بكل صراحه نعم
هذه الوزارات قسمت في بعد طافي لكن ايضا
في نفس الوقت اذا لم نمنح الكرد ولم نمنح
السنه ولم نمنح الشيعه والاحزاب وزارات
وهو نظام برلماني يحتاج رئيس الوزراء الى
دعم هذه لكي يتم التصويت عليه والتصويت
على رئيس البرلمان كيف نستطيع حقيقه ان
ناتي برئيس وزراء مباشره دون يوزع السلطه
دون ان تكون هذه القوه السياسيه لديها
يعني وجود في الوزاره وبالتالي ربما
تسالين هذا السؤال هناك خلل في الدستور
هذا الخلل ربما معالجته ستكون واحده من
العناصر المهمه
لاستقلاليه الوزارات بالعراق ممتازه من
العوامل التي ستساعد العراق على الوزارات
العراقيه لان تستقل نقطه مهمه تشير اليها
المتعلقه بالدستور سناتي اليها لكن دعني
اتحول مره اخرى دكتور يحيى اريد ان اسمع
وجهه نظرك فيما يخص الفساد صحيح ان هناك
فساد وهناك الان اعتراف بوجود هذا الفساد
وهناك رغبه حقيقيه عبر عنها اساسها
العراقيون بدء رئيس الوزراء او حتى رئيس
العراقي اليس ذلك كافيا ربما لطمانه
العراقيين كل العراقيين بان هناك رغبه
حقيقيه لت المسار
يعني هذه الدعوات التي تتحدث عن مكافحه
الفساد او محاربه الفساد تسمعيها في
العراق منذ عام 2005 الى الان بمعنى ليس
هناك اي شيء جديد فيما قاله السيد محمد
الشياع السوداني حول هذا الموضوع ولكن
لنعد الى اصل الموضوع الفساد في العراق
ليس فساد افراد الفساد في العراق هو جزء
من بنيه النظام السياسي وهو جزء من بنيه
الدوله وكل الكل شركاء فيه يعني لا
تستطيعين هنا ان تتهمني طرفا دون اخر
الجميع شركاء في هذه الفساد سلطات الدوله
بالكامل شركه في هذا الفساد القضاء شريك
في هذا الفساد يعني ساعطيك نموذجين هنا
تخيلي انه يعني تم انتخاب رئيس للجنه
النزاهه في البرلمان العراقي الجميع يعرف
انه رئيس لجنه النزاهه في البرلمان
العراقي الذي تم انتخابه يعني قبل اشهر هو
شخص مزور لشهاده المتوسطه وشهاده
الاعداديه بتقرير
صادر عن وزاره التربيه ولكن كان هناك
تواطئ جماعي على التغطيه على هذا التزوير
وتم انتخاب الرئيسه للجنه النزاهه تخيلي
ان تتحدثي عن مكافحه فساد ولجنه النزاهه
البرلمانيه يراسها مزور اعطيك مثال ثاني
ما سمي بسرقه القرن يعني تم سرقه ما يقرب
من اثنين ونصف مليار دولار من ما يسمى
بالتامينات الضريبيه السارق الرئيسي اطلق
صراحه وهو خارج نطاق السجن منذ اكثر من
خمسه اشهر اذا نحن نتحدث هنا عن نظام يحمي
الفساد يعني انا تحدثت في يعني دراسه
طويله حول طبيعه يعني عن بنيه النظام
السياسي وقلت انه بنيه النظام السياسي
العراقي على المستوى الافقي هو نظام كل
ديوقراطي لصوصي وعلى المستوى العمودي هو
نظام زبائني وبالتالي الحديث عن مكافحه
بنيه الفساد في العراق هذا يعني الحديث عن
تغيير النظام السياسي في العراق وتغيير
بنيه الدوله في العراق وهذا ليس بامكان
السيد محمد الشيعه السوداني وليس بامكان
ان رئيس مجلس الوزراء ياتي من خلال نفس
الكتل الفاسده
التغيير الذي تتحدث عنه الدكتور يحيى
الكبيسي اذا
عفوا من بامكانه احداث هذا التغيير اذا ان
قلت بان الطبقه السياسيه ليس لديها الرغبه
الحقيقيه
يعني هنا فقط الجمهور من يستطيع ان يتحرك
يعني لا احد يستطيع ان يعني ان يتخيل او
يتوهم امكانيات ان يكون هناك تغيير خارجي
التغيير الخارجي لم يعد قائما وبالتالي لا
يمكن التعويل على الطبقه السياسيه
العراقيه لاحداث تغيير على كل المستويات
بما فيها مستوى الفساد والتعويل فقط على
الجمهور الجمهور وحده هو الذي سيحصل
عن اي جمهور تتحدث يعني رغم العثرات في
بناء العراق الجديد مازال ربما اغلبيه
العراقيين يؤمنون بان خيار الديمقراطيه
افضل نظم الحكم خاصه يعني بعد التصريحات
التي يتحدث عنها ربما ساسه قطر بان الوضع
وهذا واقع يعني شهدوا حتى من زار العراق
مؤخرا الوضع بات اكثر امنا واستقرارا
التوازنات السياسيه القائمه في البلد اصلا
لا لا اعتقد هناك امكانيه لتعديل الدستور
العراقي هناك حقوق مكتسبه بنيت على اساس
هذا الدستور لا احد مستحيل مستعد للتخلي
عنها وفي اعتقاد الشخصي اذا ما ذهبنا الى
تعديل دستوري سنكون امام دستور اسوا من
دستور عام 2005 بسبب طبيعه علاقات القوه
المختله الان بمعنى على رغم من كل عوار
دستور عام 2005 ولكنه كتب في لحظه وجود
نوع من توازن القوى بوجود المحتل الامريكي
الان لا وجود لاي توازن في القوى في
العراق هناك احتكار كامل للسلطه في العراق
وبالتالي اي تعديل للدستور سيكون نتيجه
دستور اسوا من دستور 2005 تماما كما
القوانين يعني
قوانين التي يتم اقراها الان هي اسوا من
القوانين التي كانت قائمه سابقا اعود اليك
دكتور جاسم الموسوي واود ان اخذ رايك في
هذا الموضوع وانت من اثارت نقطه الدستور
نبات باعتقادك امام اجراء اي تغذيه
تعديلات على هذا الدستور اذا كان تفسير
مواده ربما يتسبب في ازمات كما يرى البعض
وقد سمعت لمداره ايضا الدكتور يحيى
لا هو دعي لي فيروز اتحدث كوني متخصص اقول
اولا النظام السياسي قبل الدستور اذا كان
احد يطالب بنظام السياسي لابد ان يفقد
عنصرين مهمين العنصر الاول مشروعيه النظام
وسلوك النظام الدستور العراقي فيه الماده
126 التي تنص على يعني مراجعه الدستور
وتغيير مواده اصطدمت بالماده 140 التي بكل
تاكيد هي مطلب كردي والكرد ركن اساسي ليس
فقط في توازن يعني القوه البرلمانيه انما
في التوازن الدولي يعني لا يستطيع العراق
ان يذهب دون ان يكون هناك راي للكرد طبعا
اجراء تغيير بالدستور بكل تاكيد يحتاج الى
اراده سياسيه وقبل وبعد الاراده السياسيه
الى سلطه تشريعيه لديها من الاستقلال
بمعنى
جاسم
سلبيه ولمده اربعه اشهر اكل لها المهمه
وهي الى حد الان لم تخرج بتوصيات لماذا
كانت كانت هناك محاولات الم من الذين تم
دعوتهم لتعديلات الدستوريه لكن ما صار
النصيب بصراحه كان هناك تعديل للدستور
وكان يفترض حقيقه ان تؤخذ الماده 126 اللي
هي
بطلب من رئيس الجمهوري ورئيس الوزراء
وبخمس اعضاء مجلس النواب يتم التعديلات
الدستوريه الدستور اصطدم بعقبتين العقبه
الاولى تعرفين المناطق المتنازع عليها لا
يمكن تعديل الفقره 140 التي تقول يجب ان
لا يعترض ثلاثه محافظات وبالتالي هي مصلحه
كرديه ولا يريدون اختلال التوازن والعقبه
الثانيه
التي اصطدم اصطدم بها الاخوان ان في
التعديلات الدستوريه في ظل هذا التوازن
اللي يتحدث عنه دكتور يحيى لا يمكن ان
نغيب ماده دستوريه بالمناسبه حتى كلمه
الجامد هي لا تعني انه جامد لا يتحرك لا
لا في نصوص وفي توقيتات لكن حتى غيرنا
ماده سيكون هناك مطلب سني مقابل هذه
الماده او مطلب شيعي مقابل هذا التغيير
وبالتالي سنعود الى المحاصصه كما هناك شلل
بالدستور بالماده التاسعه التي تنص على
يجب مراعاه التوازن وهذا خطا كبير جدا
لذلك انا اعول ست انا اعول ان الدستور
العراقي سيتم تغييره ولكن بعد تجريف الجزء
الاكبر لاحظي الدماء التي تاتي الى
البرلمان هي ليست الوجوه السابقه ولكن
العيب الباقي ان الحرس القديم رؤوس هذه
الكتل السياسيه لا زالوا يتحكمون وممكن
بالمرحله القادمه لكن ان يغير الان
الدستور
بعدد نوابه وباراده سياسيه غير الاراده
الكامله للقوى السياسيه الكرديه الشيعيه
السنيه ستكون هناك مشاكل كبيره ولا ربما
ازمات كبيره النظام الديمقراطي في العراق
نظام ديمقراطي حقيقي ولكنه بطيء ولدينا
حقيقه مراجعات حقيقيه ولدينا تصحي تصليح
في كل المجالات انا اقول المراجعه يعني
على المستوى الاكاديمي على مستوى الطبقه
المثقفه على المستوى القوى السياسيه هناك
مراجعات ولكن لا يمكن اجراء عمليه بمناسبه
واحده من شروط الاخوه الكرد هو ان يتم
تشريع قانون النفط والغاز لكي نذهب الى ما
هو ما نتحدث عنه هو تغيير بعض المواد
الدستوريه ولربما الان هناك خطوه لتشريع
قانون النفط والغاز ربما بعدها تبدا خطوه
اخرى لكن هل تتغير مواد بالدستور مواد
مهمه عولت عليها الطوائف والقوميات في هذا
الدستور لا اعتقد بهذه السرعه ستتم ولا
تتمكن اي قوه سياسيه الان نعم اعود
للدكتور يحيى وان نتساءل حقيقه عن فرص
ربما تشكيل قوه سياسيه جديده لا تقوم على
اساس طائفي او عرقي ويمكن لذلك ربما ان
يحقق هذا التغيير المنشود في البلاد
يعني الجميع يعول على ذلك مع صعوبه تحقيق
ذلك يعني كما قلت يعني تم تكريس الانقسام
المجتمعي في العراق البنيه الزبائنيه
للمجتمع العراقي حولت يعني نتحدث اليوم عن
ما اسميه دائما باقتصاد للطائفيه يعني
هناك فائده مباشره من الاعتماد على
الطائفيه والدوله تكرس هذا الامر عبر
منحها
للاحزاب الطبيعه الطائفيه السلطه الكامله
لرشوه الجمهور يعني عبر التعيينات عبر
اليات مختلفه وبالتالي في ظل يعني
الاقتصاد السياسي للطائفيه الذي يحكم
العراق اليوم من الصعب الحديث عن احزاب
عبر طائفيه ولكن هذا يعني على المدى
المتوسط والقصير مع الفشل المستمر في بنيه
النظام السياسي في العراق على الفشل
المستمر في تحقيق اي شيء الفساد المستشري
سوء الاداره كل هذا يعني
المواطن في النهايه الى البحث عن خيارات
بديله واحد هذه الخيارات البديله هي
الحديث عن احزاب او عن قوى سياسيه عبر
طائفيه ولكن كما يعني الواقع يقول ان هذا
ليس قريبا ولكن على المدى المتوسط والبعيد
ولكن فقط ملاحظه فيما يتعلق بالدستور يعني
اعتقد الحديث عن الاهميه الدستور وتعديل
الدستور حقيقه كلام عبثي في العراق لانه
لا احد يحترم الدستور ولا احد ينفذ
الدستور الدستور في العراق هو عباره عن
اداه سياسيه تستخدم من قبل القوى السياسيه
كما تشاء عبر التاويل وعبر استخدام
المحكمه الاتحاديه يعني تاويل ما لا يمكن
تاويل سياسيا بمعنى لم يعد الدستور هو
المرجع في العراق المرجع في العراق هو
علاقات القوه وبما ان هذه العلاقات هي
علاقات مختله لا احد يستطيع ان ينتظر
استقرارا مستداما حقيقيا في العراق نحن
نتحدث عن هدوء هش هذا الهدوء الهاش قابل
للانهيار في اي لحظه اعود اليك دكتور جاسم
موسوي نحاول الان ربما البحث في الدور
الاستراتيجي والاقليمي للعراق اذا ما ذكر
العراق دائما تذكر ايران والنفوذ الايراني
في العراق باعتقادك الى اي مدى العراق هو
رهينه بين الامريكيين من جهه والايرانيين
من جهه اخرى الامريكيين الذين كانوا يفترض
ان يخرج لكنهم لم يخرجوا الى اليوم يعني
لا تزال هناك تواجد عسكري امريكي في
العراق فبالتالي كيف له ان يوازن بين
الامرين مع الحفاظ على مصالح شعبه ومواطنه
يعني فقط ملاحظه هذا الدستور الذي يعاب
عليه لولاه لما شاركتم في الانتخابات ولما
تحاصصتم في السلطه وهذا الدستور هو الذي
فصل بين السلطات ولا ما كان هناك فصلا
للحريات للمواطن العراقي وهذا الدستور هو
الذي ضمنه سلامه الدوله العراقيه
وبالمناسبه هذا الدستور في اغلب مواده شرع
القوانين من اجل الدوله وليس كنظام
الانظمه السابقه شرع القوانين من اجل
الاثبات وجوده هذا مهم جدا بالنسبه لسؤالك
الكريم علاقه العراق مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بالتاكيد لن تذهب الى يعني فصل
مليء بالمشاكل اكيد هناك
علاقه استراتيجيه مهمه بجانب الامريكي كان
له دور كبير في اسقاط الديكتاتوريه وايضا
العراق له اهميه ولكن تعرفين ايضا الموقف
العراقي هو يريد ان يحدد الادوار
الامريكيه في العراق خصوصا بعد ان استخدمت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه للاراضي
العراقيه الاستهدافات منها الشهيدين
العزيزين سليماني والمهندس وبالتالي اذا
ما يعني استفادت امريكا من الموقف السياسي
الذي كان يتهم به الاطار انه سيكون معادي
هو موقف ايجابي بمبني على اساس تحديد
القوه الامريكيه هل هم مستشارين ام قوه
قتاليه والعراق لا احتاج الى ذلك ولكن لن
يذهب العراق
ليذهب الى اي دوله اخرى تكون بديله عن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولا اعتقد
ايضا امريكا قادره عن تستغني عن العراق
الجديد العراق القديم لن يعود والوضع
الاقليمي لن يقضي كمال
يحيى اسمح لي دكتور جاسم لديها اهميه
استراتيجيه تماما بالنسبه للعراق دكتور
يحيى في عجاله نبدا نتحدث عن البعد العربي
والتحديات التي تواجه مفتاح العراق على
الدول العربيه خاصه الخليج كان هناك تقارب
او ما يبدو رغبه في التقارب بين السعوديه
والعراق الاتفاق الايراني السعودي ايضا
كيف سيينعكس باعتقادك على العراق
لا اعتقد ان هناك استراتيجيه علاقات
خارجيه للعراق تجاه الدول العربيه تماما
كما ليس هناك استراتيجيه للعلاقات
الخارجيه لدول الاقليم العربيه مع العراق
وايران هي المحدده الاساسي لطبيعه العلاقه
بسبب طبيعه النظام في العراق يعني
بالنهايه نحن نتحدث عن تغول ايراني في
العراق عن دور ايراني كبير في صياغه
القرار السياسي العراقي وبالتالي يعني لا
احد يستطيع ان يعول على قرار ذاتي عراقي
القوه الاساسيه تحديدا التي تشكل الحكومه
الان هي اقرب الى ايران منها الى موقف
مستقل
تماما دكتور يحيى الكبيسي ضيفنا الكريم من
اسطنبول كما اشكر جزيل الشكر الدكتور جاسم
الموسوي ضيفنا الكريم من بغداد خاتم
حلقتنا دمتم في رعايه الله والسلام عليكم
[موسيقى]